let me know if you've ever been in this
situation you're sitting down writing
something and you've been struggling for
hours trying to find the right words
it's super painful and frustrating and
no good ideas are coming to your head
but all of a sudden something hits you
the right words magically seem to just
come to you it's like you've been mining
in a cold dark cave for days and you
finally struck gold
or maybe you're playing around on the
piano trying to improvise something
you're not really coming up with
anything good but then all of a sudden
you try something new and you somehow
pull off a brilliant new melody it's
like genius struck for a brief moment
and then faded from existence moments
like these seem to fall upon us kind of
randomly and without warning while we're
in them it's almost euphoric things kind
of click together and start making sense
like the pieces to a giant complex
puzzle are starting to snap themselves
together but most of the time this just
isn't how things go practicing an
instrument is usually tedious and boring
writing is difficult but as we're
trudging through these activities we
remember those brief bouts of brilliance
and we hope that this time when we're
participating in our craft it can be
like that one time when things just
clicked although they may seem like it
these little flashes of brilliance
aren't just random and nonsensical they
are a window through which we can catch
a glimpse of our potential it's like a
little preview of the power which we all
possess inside of us a power that makes
this elusive state of brilliance and
creativity into a consistent and
replicable reality and if we're able to
fully develop this power it can give us
a greater command over ourselves over
others and over the world around us this
power is called mastery
now when most people think of the word
mastery they think of somebody who's
really good at something Beethoven was a
master composer and musician and most
people would say that Martin Scorsese is
a master filmmaker but mastery is a lot
more than just being really good at
something because the master has such a
thorough understanding of his craft that
it becomes like an extension of himself
it becomes a language they can use to
influence and inspire other people in a
way that seems almost magical a master
piece of literature can bring us to
tears of joy or tears of bitter sadness
and a master painting can cause us to
reflect on the fleeting nature of time
or the nature of our very existence it's
as if the master through their expertise
has access to something like the heart
of life but a lot of people disqualify
themselves from ever achieving mastery
in whatever their craft is you know if
you're a normal person like you or me we
tend to think that we're incapable of
achieving mastery like some of the
Great's before us we may be tempted to
think that mastery is reserved for the
genius or the child prodigy but the
truth is mastery is something that
already exists inside you and it's up to
you to develop it so how does one go
about developing their mastery well you
may have heard that it takes 10,000
hours of practice to become a master at
something and this is kind of true you
do need an insane amount of practice at
your given craft in order to achieve
mastery but it isn't just a numbers game
you're probably never going to put in
that amount of time practicing a craft
if you don't actually enjoy it which is
why the first step of mastery is to
discover your calling everyone who has
ever lived has at least one thing that
sets their imagination on fire something
we feel naturally drawn towards or
fascinated by whether that's
constructing something or solving a
problem or playing an instrument because
of your unique brain you have certain
things that you really dislike doing and
certain things that you really have a
preference for so really reflect on your
life and figure out what
your passions lie if you really like
doing something and you feel in
importance while doing it then that's an
indication that you can potentially
become a master in this thing but
passion alone won't get you far the
second step on the road to mastery is to
eliminate the ego realize that you know
absolutely nothing and become a blank
canvas
you need to seek every opportunity to
grow and view everything as a potential
learning experience approach your craft
with a ruthless objectivity don't
identify as being good or talented at
anything because that puts a barrier in
the way of viewing your work objectively
and being critical about it a good
example of me not doing this was when I
was in a filmmaking class and I always
carry it around this sense of pride
about my filmmaking ability I was
usually the best filmmaker in a room but
I'm usually in a room where nobody makes
films so that's pretty easy my now a
good friend Jared also made films hid
read to be my video okay okay
right now before I knew him really well
he would present his work to the class
and it was pretty good and I would feel
threatened by this because I'm supposed
to be a good filmmaker and for some
reason his work being good was a threat
to that it doesn't make any sense but
that's because the ego is involved you
need to eliminate the need to be the
best artist in the room or the best at
your craft or the best athlete because
when you're trying to learn as much as
possible none of that matters if you can
eliminate the ego then you can view the
work of your peers and figure out what
they're doing better than you are and
then you can apply that to your own work
it also allows you to look at your own
work with a ruthless objectivity as well
and scrutinize it more
this video is pretty trash find out
where your weak spots are and try to
make them strengths none of this is
possible if you have a giant ego and
identify as a master long before you've
earned that title step number three on
the road to mastery is to learn to
embrace tedium when you first approach a
craft you approach it
as an apprentice practicing your craft
for the most part is going to be tedious
it's not going to be very exciting
applying new techniques and trying to
stretch your boundaries is usually
really uncomfortable boring and not very
exciting I fell so bad
but if you learn to embrace the tedious
nature of practicing your craft day
after day you'll eventually reach a
point of accelerated return you start to
become a practitioner and the
practitioner understands the complex
relationships between each component of
their craft they start to get a view of
the bigger picture they can really
engage with their craft in a more
creative way once you reach this stage
in the game practicing becomes a lot
less tedious and more enjoyable you can
start to have some fun with it but the
road doesn't end there
you still need to propel yourself into
mastery you still need to find that
deeper understanding and one of the most
effective ways you can do this is to
move on to step number four which is
absorb the Masters power since you've
become a practitioner you can use your
competency in your craft as sort of a
proof that you take it seriously and
you're willing to learn you can then
take this proof to somebody who's much
better than you at your craft and work
under them it's crucial that you find
somebody who's much better than you at
what you do and learn from them so that
you don't have to reinvent the wheel
your work can also be scrutinized by
somebody who has the authority to
scrutinize it by learning from a master
you can then view your own work through
their eyes and try to work on things
that they would want you to work on and
working alongside a master
collaboratively is a great way to become
one yourself but if you're unwilling to
take this path towards mastery then this
creative power inside you will remain
undeveloped it will lie dormant it will
occasionally reveal itself in these
little glimmers of temporary brilliance
begging to be fully realized
in case it wasn't already clear this
entire video was based off of the book
mastery by Robert Greene and it's one of
my favorite books I've read this year
and I'd highly recommend checking out
the audiobook version of mastery using
today's video sponsor audible because
that's exactly how I read the book I
really like it when audible sponsors my
videos because they're super easy to
recommend I probably listen to more
audiobooks than I read physical books
nowadays audiobooks are great for
listening to good literature when you're
on the go if you're working out going
for a run if you're doing something
monotonous that doesn't take much
thought you might as well be expanding
your mind in the process not only does
audible have the largest selection of
audiobooks on the entire internet but
every single month you can download one
audiobook for free regardless of cost as
well as two audible originals so to sign
up for your free 30-day trial click the
link in the description visit
audible.com slash for better ideas or
text better ideas to 500 500 and one of
my favorite things about odd what do I
do with my hands if you cancel your
subscription you still keep your entire
library of books once again click the
link in the description or text better
ideas - 500 500 - start your free 30-day
trial and have a good time so this video
took me a long time to make mostly
because it just took me a long time to
write I wrote probably 8,000 words about
mastery because it's such a rich book
but I wrote a lot of things and they
weren't necessarily all connected in
this nice through line so it's really
hard for me to try to figure out how to
distill such a rich book packed with
information into a under 10 minute video
but hopefully you can find something
useful out of it but if you like this
video make sure to hit like because we
hit like the algorithm does fancy things
and it helps my face show up in on your
home page and it really helps spread the
channel if you're lurking here consider
subscribing and hitting the bell icons
so that you don't miss future videos I'm
having a Q a really soon on my second
channel I'll put the link in the
description to that it should be a lot
of fun other than that that's all for
today thanks a lot for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video
[Music]